vamos a tratar de crear algo genial
usando estos productos y vamos a seguir
el proceso de innovación y lluvia de
ideas y tratar de resolver los problemas
que nos encontremos cuando queramos
hacer que todos estos elementos
funcionen juntos pueden ver que tenemos
aquí una cámara digital la secadora
vemos un reloj despertador
esta es una grabadora digital que
conseguimos en una tienda de
electrónicos la lámpara de toque que es
una lámpara led que funciona con
baterías y vamos a pensar cómo usar todo
esto junto para crear algo útil
vamos a tomar nuestro cuaderno y a
dibujar diferentes conceptos de lo que
podemos crear con estas cosas me gustan
las dimensiones de la lámpara vamos a
tratar de usarla primero la secadora de
pelo tiene motores y sabemos que estos
motores pueden impulsar a la lámpara o
mover algo así que dibujamos la lámpara
con los motores también podríamos usar
el cuerpo del reloj en despertador para
crear un robot que se mueva y
necesitaremos ruedas para esto y quizás
podamos usar los motores de la secadora
o del dvd me interesa crear algo con
personalidad y que pueda moverse algo
que responda a su ambiente y usar los
productos que ya les ensamblamos para
crear algo nuevo algo que quizás pueda
tomar fotos y también grabar o
reproducir sonidos
ahora que tenemos claros nuestros
objetivos debemos preguntarnos cómo
vamos a hacer que funcione vamos a
aislar cada uno de estos objetivos y lo
vamos a escribir aquí abajo indicando
los componentes que vamos a usar para
lograrlo sabemos que se va a mover y
para esto nos sirven los motores de la
secadora podemos usar dos de ellos quizá
para que soplen aire y mueva nuestro
dispositivo o podríamos hacer que hagan
girar unas ruedas para que interactúe
con el ambiente
podemos usar un interruptor o sensor
podríamos usar los sensores del reloj
despertador para que si toca una pared
pueda girar y alejarse y podemos usar la
grabadora y la cámara para grabar
imágenes y sonido pero como controlamos
todo esto vamos a necesitar un
microcontrolador ya elegimos cuál usar
tenemos la cámara y tarjeta de sonido
nuestros motores de la secadora y por
supuesto nuestra lámpara de toque y
probablemente la usemos como el cuerpo
de nuestro nuevo dispositivo vamos a
necesitar algo para dar corriente a
nuestro dispositivo que son las baterías
el primer problema que encontramos es
que
motores funcionan con 12 volts y sabemos
que la tarjeta de sonido funciona con 9
volts y la cámara funciona con 4.5 volts
nuestro microcontrolador arduino usa 5
volts así que todo funciona con voltajes
diferentes por lo que tenemos que
encontrar una forma de controlar estos
voltajes y hacer que todo funcione
correctamente y esto lo podemos lograr
con un controlador del motor ya que nos
permite regular la cantidad de voltaje
que va a requerir cada motor y controlar
nuestros motores de alto voltaje con
nuestro arduino de menor voltaje más
adelante veremos esto con más detalle en
el vídeo sobre el controlador del motor
comencemos abriendo la secadora para
quitar el motor y ya que esto es lo que
vamos a usar para mover nuestro
dispositivo vamos a experimentar un poco
con él y ver cuánta energía necesita
cuánto torque tiene y cosas por el
estilo
vamos a experimentar con este usando
nuestras pinzas cocodrilo y vamos a usar
una batería de 1.5 volts o batería doble
para ver si podemos hacer que gire el
motor y darnos cuenta de cuánto aire
empuja con estos 1.5 volts aquí tengo un
pedazo de plástico para probar el motor
lo ponemos enfrente y vemos que el aire
del motor casi no lo mueve por lo que no
nos va a servir y vamos a necesitar un
mayor voltaje esto lo hacemos combinando
las baterías en un soporte o caja para
baterías lo que nos permite tener las
baterías en serie así que pasamos de 1.5
volts a más de 12 volts ya que estas
pilas son nuevas
veamos cuál es el impacto de esto en
nuestro motor conectamos nuestras
baterías a nuestro motor y vaya qué
reacción tuvo el motor se está moviendo
mucho más rápido y ahora el plástico es
empujado a un lado vemos que está
expulsando bastante aire pero no creo
que usemos este método para mover
nuestro dispositivo
aunque expulse mucho aire solo funciona
efectivamente en una sola dirección pues
está diseñado para soplar aire
únicamente fuera de la secadora vamos a
determinar las especificaciones del
motor para saber que necesita para
funcionar para esto debemos quitar el
ventilador y la cubierta exterior del
motor lo cortamos con nuestra segueta y
adelantamos el vídeo para que no tengan
que esperar hasta que terminemos este
ventilador es muy grueso y difícil de
cortar ya que es lo que protege el motor
e hicieron un buen trabajo con esto
sobre todo para que no se mueva con el
movimiento de la secadora vamos a cortar
el resto del ventilador para poder
llegar al motor y vamos a quitar los
últimos tornillos
ahora sí ya tenemos el motor y vamos a
ver si encontramos las especificaciones
y hay texto impreso justo aquí ahora
vamos a buscar este texto en la red para
determinar qué tipo de motor tenemos
aquí y cuáles son sus especificaciones
es bueno incluir el nombre de lo que
buscamos junto con el texto que
escribamos en nuestro buscador aquí
encontramos una hoja de especificaciones
de motores caixa y vamos a ver si
encontramos nuestro texto y aquí está el
modelo 20 73 el voltaje de operación
está entre 9 y 24 volts el voltaje a
nominal está alrededor de 20 volts
sin carga el motor dará vueltas a 17 mil
200 revoluciones por minuto lo que es
muy rápido y soporta 0.2 amperes de
corriente y siempre vamos a operar sin
carga por lo que siempre estaremos
sacando más de 0.2 amperes
la rapidez del motor su eficiencia
máxima está en 14.420 la corriente en
eficiencia máxima es de un am pero
cuando estás sin carga
el torque está en 9.49 newtonmetros o
96.7 gramos centímetros esta es la
fuerza de torsión o torque que puede
generar el motor y es un número
importante de conocer y parece que será
suficiente para mover nuestro
dispositivo también el motor puede
generar una salida de 14.3 watts el
número clave que debemos recordar es el
voltaje debemos asegurarnos de operar
dentro del rango de voltaje que soporta
el motor si usamos nuestras baterías en
serie como lo hicimos hace rato
generamos 12 volts lo que está en el
rango de 9 y 20 volts de operación del
motor por lo que no debemos tener
problemas al operarlo y vamos a
controlar la rapidez del motor con
nuestro arduino y nuestro controlador
del motor el arduino enviará un pulso
modulado al motor lo que cambiará la
rapidez
y ahora que vaya mucho más despacio que
si tuviera la corriente directa